vorrei che provate a ricordarvi
dell'ultima volta in cui vi siete persi
le l'ultima volta in cui vi sia capitato
di ritrovarmi in una situazione come
questa non a consultare un quotidiano
con un cappello a causa il bordo della
strada
ovviamente di smarrirvi nel tentativo di
girovagare per una città sconosciuta in
un luogo poco conosciuto
beh sono quasi certo che se chiedessi a
qualcuno di voi se gli sia successo
recentemente di perdersi e chiede sì a
coloro a cui sia successo di alzare la
mano qui in sala le mani alzate
sarebbero poche possiamo provare quanti
si sono persi negli ultimi cinque anni
beh ok diciamo che tutti coloro che
invece non hanno vissuto questa
esperienza sono stati aiutati da una
tecnologia che da qualche anno a questa
parte è a portata di mano e anche a
portata di tasca e quella che tutti
chiamiamo impropriamente gps
impropriamente vedremo perché ma il gps
e soltanto l'ennesima soluzione
tecnologica che l'essere umano è
riuscito ad escogitare per risolvere un
problema così primitivo che qualcuno lo
definirebbe addirittura un senso il
senso dell'orientamento
appunto sappiamo che scientificamente il
concetto di senso è decisamente labile
ma ci basti pensare almeno per questa
sera che il 6 e il senso
dell'orientamento congiunge una serie di
capacità che l'essere umano acquisito
nella storia tra cui la localizzazione e
la navigazione con la prima intendiamo
la capacità di determinare la nostra
posizione rispetto ad un sistema di
riferimento condiviso mentre con la
seconda descriviamo il modo in cui
procediamo da un punto di partenza ad
una destinazione da un punto a a un
punto b
quali caratteristiche a il nostro modo
la velocità l'accelerazione
ho qualche passo indietro di qualche
anno ormai dovremmo ricordarci come si
utilizzavano questi strumenti così
antichi oggi le cartine stradali le
mappe beh per navigare e posizionarci
con questi strumenti
facevamo continuamente riferimento alla
realtà circostante confrontandola con le
caratteristiche rappresentate sulla
cartina stessa
in questo modo definivamo una serie di
dettagli della realtà riportati in scala
semplificati sulla cartina che
chiamavamo punti di riferimento così
come erano punti di riferimento i fari
per gli antichi navigatori oggetti
luminosi disposti lungo la costa per
favorire la navigazione delle navi in
zone costiere appunto sfiderei però
chiunque di voi a mettere in gioco le
proprie capacità e il proprio senso
dell'orientamento in una situazione
decisamente meno confortevole come ad
esempio questa la navigazione in mare
aperto
magari in una giornata come questa in
pieno giorno senza la possibilità
neppure di osservare la posizione del
sole rispetto a voi
ebbene vi assicuro che le vostre
capacità di orientamento in questa
situazione sarebbero totalmente azzerate
come si è risolta questa situazione
anticamente gli antichi navigatori
capirono subito che potevano fare
affidamento su una particolare fortuna
che si potrebbe definire in un certo
senso astronomica che non riguarda solo
il pianeta terra ma tutti i pianeti
l'asse di rotazione del nostro pianeta è
infatti approssimativamente orientato
verso una stella quella che conosciamo
tutti come stella polare polaris una
stella fissa della costellazione
dell'orsa minore che ha rappresentato
per secoli la bussola degli antichi
navigatori sì perché un singolo punto di
riferimento nel cielo che non subisce il
moto apparente del resto della volta
celeste può fornire unicamente
un'indicazione simile a quella di una
bussola gli antichi greci erano capaci
di determinare la
latitudine osservando l'angolo che la
stella formava rispetto all'orizzonte
quello che oggi chiamiamo elevazione
ebbene non è sicuramente sufficiente una
bussola per navigare ed è per questo che
se cerchiamo la definizione di bus da su
wikipedia
vediamo che una bussola insieme ad un
orologio e ad un sé stante forniscono un
accuratissimo sistema di navigazione ma
non discuterei dell'efficacia di questa
definizione chiunque può irritare
wikipedia probabilmente questa voce la
scritta qualcuno di voi ma sono sicuro
che i ricercatori del gruppo di
navigazione di cui faccio parte quel
politecnico di torino avrebbero qualcosa
da ridire sul concetto di accuratissimo
e lo dimostra il fatto che nessuno di
voi e spero in questo caso che le mani
alzate siano un po meno di prima
abbia un sé stante in tasca ma l'ho
confermato che le donne
ok ma lasciamo da parte per un attimo
sostante ormai in disuso da diverso
tempo ma perché mai un orologio beh il
motivo se vogliamo è semplice se non
possiamo fare affidamento su punti di
riferimento fissi come lo è la stella
polare
siamo costretti ad appoggiarci a punti
di riferimento mobili o sono loro stessi
a spostarci possiamo noi a spostarci
rispetto a loro ebbene in questo caso
capire in che istante li stiamo
osservando è di vitale importanza per
comprendere la nostra posizione e quindi
il tempo il secondo ingrediente
fondamentale per un sistema di
posizionamento di navigazione il tempo
che anticamente veniva misurato come
vedete a sinistra meccanicamente ma si
misura oggi in modo estremamente più
preciso grazie all'uso di orologi
atomici orologi che funzionano grazie
alla frequenza di risonanza di alcuni
elementi fondamentali come il cesio
l'idrogeno alluminio e molti altri e che
sono in grado di perdere un singolo
secondo nell'arco di 15 miliardi di anni
più dell'età dell'intero universo
questi sono gli orologi che oggi
garantiscono a noi la precisione sulla
misura del tempo
ecco che abbiamo definito gli
ingredienti fondamentali di un sistema
di navigazione i punti di riferimento e
il
partendo dai primi nel 1960 il
dipartimento della difesa degli stati
uniti decise di escogitare una soluzione
piuttosto economica e pratica che fu
quella di lanciare in orbita una serie
di satelliti per favorire a tutti le
proprie capacità di navigazione e
posizionamento
nacque così progetto transit che fu
creato è progettato per scopi
squisitamente bellici per controllare il
moto dei missili balistici
ma fu di fatto l'antenato di quello che
oggi conosciamo con il nome di gps
global positioning system un insieme di
32 satelliti che dal 1973 ci garantisce
la possibilità di posizionarci in
qualunque punto del globo e in qualunque
momento
ebbene se facciamo qualche passo
indietro anche in questo caso
capiamo che però fino agli anni 2000
nessuno di noi poteva fare uso di
navigatori satellitari i primi
navigatori satellitari per auto
comparvero successivamente al 2000
proprio perché in quel periodo il
sistema ips era ancora affetto da un
disturbo volontario che riduceva la
precisione e lo avrebbe reso
praticamente inutilizzabile per gli
scopi per cui lo utilizziamo oggi anche
sulla terraferma il progresso è stato
velocissimo così veloce che in
pochissimi anni si è riusciti a
realizzare ricevitori così piccoli che
ne ho in tasca uno dall'inizio del talk
e nessuno se n'è neppure accorto ma all
80 per cento dei ricevitori gps o gnss
per essere più corretti risiede nei
nostri smartphone ed entro pochissimi
anni questi dispositivi saranno più di
10 miliardi su questo pianeta
aggiungerei che oltre a essere capaci di
geolocalizzarsi saranno anche
interconnessi fra loro e tendente a
mente questo dettaglio abbiamo creato un
sistema straordinario le nostre moderne
stelle che si vedono anche quando le
condizioni metereologiche non sono
ideali
gli orologi più precisi che l'essere
umano sia stato in grado di concepire ma
sin segnali che riceviamo e la strada
che calcoliamo non fosse quella giusta
mi credereste se vi dicessi che potreste
perdervi anche basandovi su un
ricevitore gps
sì perché non si tratta solo di navigare
si tratta di mantenere attive una serie
di infrastrutture da cui dipendiamo
quotidianamente le più insospettabili le
reti di telecomunicazioni ad esempio il
download e l'upload e arbitrato secondo
il tempo scandito dai sistemi di
navigazione
le griglie di distribuzione dell'energia
elettrica anche in questo caso arbitrate
e temporizzate dal segnare di tempo dei
sistemi di navigazione
ultimo ma non meno importante le
microtransazioni ad alta frequenza del
mercato finanziario
ora tutte queste infrastrutture hanno
iniziato ad utilizzare il gps non perché
fosse necessario ma perché era semplice
accessibile ubiquo ma soprattutto
gratuito immaginate ora se il servizio
di navigazione dovesse interrompersi un
recente studio ci dice che tutto questo
costerebbe all'umanità un miliardo di
dollari al giorno senza considerare
tutti gli aerei che probabilmente
perderebbero la strada capiamo subito
che un'interruzione portata da fenomeni
naturali come l'interazione delle
tempeste solari con la ionosfera
potrebbe essere veramente veramente
catastrofica per la nostra società così
fortemente centralizzata sulla
tecnologia e su questa tecnologia ma ci
sono interventi umani volontari che
possono mettere a rischio le tecnologie
di navigazione
come vedete da queste da questi articoli
di cronaca recente l'anno scorso una
sfida di droni che si è tenuta a lungo
il po è stata interrotta da un attacco
di questo tipo
vedete che ci sono altre notizie battute
da importanti riviste anche scientifiche
che testimoniano che questo rischio è
tangibile e reale attuale si chiamano
attacchi di spoofing di mico ning ed è
sufficiente mettere insieme alcuni
componenti elettronici come quelli che
sono contenuti in questa valigetta per
poter dirottare un sistema di
navigazione che basi la sua capacità di
orientarsi sul sistema di localizzazione
satellitare non è legale accendere
questa valigetta e infatti non lo farò
ma se lo fosse nel momento esatto in cui
io e si alimentazione a questo sistema
la maggior parte dei vostri smartphone
si localizza rebbero a helsinki la città
che ho configurato in questo sistema
un'altra buona metà invece sarebbero
diventerebbero inutilizzabili di fatto
ecco non è legale perché per legge non
si può trasmettere sulle frequenze
utilizzate per la radio navigazione ma
vi basti pensare che un oggetto di
questo tipo per il quale non servono
particolari competenze né
dell'elettronica nella navigazione e con
meno di 500 euro realizzabile basterebbe
per dirottare sistemi commerciali di
navigazione e l'abbiamo fatto
no ma l'aria aperta perché appunto non
si può ma in una camera anecoica una
save son che ci ha permesso di testare
questo tipo di attacchi e purtroppo
molti dei dispositivi commerciali che
integrano sistemi di navigazione
satellitare ricevitori sono stati
hackerati se così vogliamo dire
fotocamere digitali smartphone droni che
stanno spopolando sia nel mercato sia
nei cieli ma soprattutto scatole nere
quelle che le compagnie assicurative
installano nelle vostre automobili per
monitorare i vostri spostamenti fare
qualche sconto sulle polizze oppure per
imparare qualcosa in più dai vostri dati
ebbene non siamo al sicuro da questo
tipo di attacchi per lo meno non per ora
l'agenzia spaziale europea e il
dipartimento della difesa degli stati
uniti lavorano a ritmi serrati per
garantire la sicurezza dei sistemi di
navigazione satellitare e una strada
sarà sicuramente quella
dell'autenticazione dei segnali sarà
possibile ai ricevitori distinguere
quali segnali provengano di fatto dai
satelliti e quali altri invece
provengono da altre fonti non
autorizzato a trasmettere
ma prima che tutto ciò possa essere
realtà ci vorrà del tempo perché si
tratta di aggiornare l'intero sistema
capite che non è molto pratico
raggiungere un satellite in orbita 20
mila chilometri di distanza per
modificare il sistema attuale abbiamo
deciso allora di provarci direttamente
qui sulla terra ferma
di unire quei 10 miliardi di dispositivi
in grado di comunicare fra loro alle
informazioni di distanza che vengono
misurate ogni secondo dai dispositivi
stessi e cercare quelli che in gergo non
vengono chiamati in gergo vengono
definiti out l'ayers ovvero componenti
elementi di questa rete come potrebbe
essere lo smartphone di ciascuno di voi
che stanno misurando qualcosa che non è
conforme alle misure degli altri
in questo modo saremo in grado di
permettere a quel dato dispositivo di
comprendere di essere sotto attacco
ci auguriamo che questa semplice
intuizione in parallelo allo sviluppo di
tecnologie robuste come ad esempio
l'autenticazione dei segnali impedisca a
quale ma a qualche male intenzionato un
giorno di prendere possesso del nostro
del vostro nuovo e fiammante veicolo
guida autonoma decidendo di portarlo e
condurlo a parcheggiare nel proprio box
anziché nel vostro
ci auguriamo più sicurezza anche per le
tecnologie di navigazione grazie e buona
navigazione a tutti
[Applauso]